if you want to hear how one forgotten
scene from the book makes a little
Easter egg appearance in this movie then
stick around to the end of this video
this video is sponsored by a rake on
welcome to things you missed today we
continue the careth on yeah I'm calling
it that now with yet another remake of
Carrie with this one while not as
subliminal as the original this is
actually pretty good and make some
improvements and has some of its own
secrets so why don't we explore them
the volleyball game from the novel has
been changed to pool volleyball for the
reaming I think it makes a lot of sense
because the maturity of the female body
is a major theme and carry and the
swimsuits are just gonna highlight that
it's also putting them in a pool gives
more of a reason for the shower seem to
exist in order to wash off that chlorine
since in this time period most kids
would just slap on some deodorant after
a regular gym class
mr. Jardin basically looked like
mystique and Pokemon in the same misty
is a water type trainer and the gym
leader of the Cerulean City Gym while Ms
D trains her students in the water and
is the gym teacher of the UN high school
gym misty is known for nurturing the
awkward and misunderstood Saida
and miss D forms a special bond with
carry wives when Kerri gets her first
period in the shower after class I
noticed the sign in the locker room
which could foreshadow something that
happens in the prom scene where the
twins slip and fall on the wet floor I
think there's a similar foreshadowing
going on with these umbrellas in Susan
Elle's house to set up the sprinklers at
the prom and when Kerri uses her mind to
break the locker room mirror which sets
up this part and this part lately we've
seen a number of Stephen King's novels
get adapted for a second time like Pet
Sematary and it but this movie seems to
want us to know that it's just as much
of a remake of Brian De Palma's 1976
film than it is a readapt ation of the
novel the car that Billy Nolan drives
looks the same the theme of the problem
seems to once again be love among the
stars as opposed to springtime in Venice
from the novel Carrie's dress is pink or
at least starts out that way Carrie's
mother is crucified and Sue's nails
nightmare at the end is reimagined and
this isn't something that's in the book
at all after recording Carrie's meltdown
in the locker room Chris Hargensen who
is so narcissistic that she has a
picture of herself uploads it to YouTube
and it actually kind of gives me anxiety
that the tags and description aren't
properly filled out the girls who
bullied Carrie are forced to run sprints
but the rules are a little bit different
than in the original that's up to all of
you but anyone who stops running is
suspended and if you're suspended
you're not going to prom I kind of feel
like that's not that effective because
the girls were the most guilty are
pretty fit so continuing to run wouldn't
really be that big of a deal for them
compared to the others anyway while this
is going on Carrie is excused from gym
and picks up some books from the library
one of which is called telekinesis
analysis and aftermath in the novel the
story is broken up by excerpts from
books articles and interviews about the
Carrie White incident and about the
telekinesis phenomenon and this is one
of the many publications that is quoted
the poem Carrie reads from in English
clash is an excerpt from John Milton's
1671 poem Samson Agonistes
that's how you say it it to hints at the
tragic ending of the story with lines
like from restless thoughts that like a
deadly swarm of Hornets armed which
connected to the idea of carries
thoughts literally being deadly because
she can destroy things with her mind and
of both my parents all in flames
ascended which ties into her mother's
idea that Carrie was born out of sin and
of course the fiery ending of the senior
prom one of the things that I mentioned
at the beginning is how there are some
little improvements in certain areas
like how were really shown the weight of
Sue's decision to miss the prom in this
one the fact that she's been dreaming of
it since she was young how she already
has a dress picked out and how everyone
expects her to be there there are also
some creative uses of the telekinesis
like how Carrie uses it to flip the
light switch moments before her mother
walks in using it to hold down the foot
pedal on the sewing machine without
actually using her foot and perhaps the
most lazy one I've ever seen using it to
turn on the radio
it's right there Carrie it's literally
right there so sue asked her boyfriend
Tommy Ross to take Carrie to the prom as
always but this time rather than Tommy
being a baseball player football phenom
or a track star he keeps up with the
theme of this being set in 2013 and
plays lacrosse should he gone with
ultimate had gone with ultimate however
Carrie's mother does not approve of her
attending the prom let's roll that blood
smell I was gonna take you carry in his
car out to the wilderness out where so
cold no road houses are on the whiskey
in the novel road houses in whiskey are
one of those things that come up again
and again as a symbol of evil in the
eyes of mrs. White's for example her
father was killed in a road house her
husband impregnated her with the smell
of Roadhouse whiskey on his breath and
at the end of the book Carrie chases
Chris Hargensen and Billy Nolan into a
Roadhouse called the cavalier which by
the way is represented by an Easter egg
in the movie a bunch of people were
going to the Cavalier after the Cavalier
is where Chris and Billy sleeps
sometimes and where they devised the
plan to humiliate Carrie the movie also
shows step one of that plan going into
action when Billy and his friends go to
the pig farm don't worry little piggy
Uncle Jack he's gonna bash your head
right in they just really couldn't help
themselves in this franchise could they
I'm just gonna bash your brains
I'm gonna bash right in the day of the
prom would soon arrive Carrie and Tommy
hang with Tommy's friend George and his
date Erika who goes to a different
school called over it actually works
well that she's from another school
because she has no reason to think that
Carrie is weird at all that was actually
me at the prom the kid from another
school but if you ask me
Sue Snell is the real weird one in this
movie her boyfriend is literally the
only conversation in her phone this
supposed prom queen favorite seriously
only talks to one person come on if you
pause the movie as the students are
filling out their votes for prom king
and queen there are even more easter
eggs and other things you missed the
prom scene and Carrie is often referred
to as the black prom I always find it
strange how something so tragic can
sound so similar to something so sweet
like Black Friday the day where you're
gonna be getting incredible deals on
rate on your books using my link in the
description right now I've got a pair of
recon earbuds I've been using these
things all the time they're already half
the cost of other premium wireless
earbuds before my discount they're
comfortable no annoying stems or wires
and they stay in your ear while you're
doing stuff look at this what I love
about them is that clean isolated
quality sound that they deliver straight
to your ears plus you don't have to
worry about battery life the latest
model left six hours so you could use
them to watch all three Carrey movies
back to back if you wanted to which I
may have done with more base a compact
design great color options and a
charging case that extends your battery
life to 24 hours there has never been a
better time to pick up some Raycom great
gift idea just click the link in the
description to get early access to rake
on the Black Friday and Cyber Monday
deals I can't even tell you how good the
deals will be you have to check them out
on the website by Raycom slash Jeezy's
world
[Music]
there's a lot more than what meets the
eye on the prom king and queen ballots
first we got Frank rear and Jessica
Frank was a football player in the book
and Jessica Upshaw was one of the
bullies George says Marv and Frieda
Jason
George was the most renowned artist at
the school who created the murals
displayed at the prom and Frieda is his
girlfriend these writings are a joke
Morton and discharge important if you
don't remembers the assistant principal
and the startin is the gym teacher so I
imagine this ballot was filled by one of
the girls who was punished for bullying
Carrie white and still upset about
Morton and discharged and Timmy option
to shut the punishments Don Farnum and
Helen shires Don's only mentioned in the
book is that he's dating Helen and Helen
is another one of the bullies after
Tommy Ross and Carrie White we've got
Bryan Cranston and Emma Tamblyn Bryan
not to be confused with the dad from
Malcolm in the middle gets his name from
the onset carpenter of Cary he also
worked on its end at chapter 2 and Emma
worked in the costume department not
sure about Peter Nikola caicos but Myra
Cruz is a minor character in the novel
and finally Jordan Samuel and Susan
Riley Lehane Jordan was the head of the
makeup department and Susan was the
makeup artist for Julianne Moore this
one might be the coolest-looking blood
spill although I don't know if I can
show it Carrie forced jokes mr. Jordan
hopefully I can show that and after
destroying the prom returns home to face
her mother Margaret White's only real
hobby seems to be sewing so I found it
kind of cool that Carrie uses that
against her by impaling her with her own
tools wait where have I seen this before
nothing more terrifying than that
finally Carrie uses her telekinesis to
bring down the entire house but there's
one small moment where we actually see
what is destroying it after lifting up
her mother a rock can be seen punching
through the ceiling and landing on this
dresser this is a reference to an event
from the book known as the rain of
stones which is documented in a weekly
magazine that tells of the incident that
took place when Carrie was a little girl
it counts from the whites neighbors say
that one day after Margaret upset her
rock started to fall from the sky but
only above the whites house and pierced
through the roof tiles while Carrie was
having a meltdown however the story
never really became mainstream because
by the time the media showed up mrs.
white had already had the roof repaired
but all the neighbors swear by what
happened the scene has only been adapted
in the 2002 TV movie where the stones
looking more like meteors apparently it
was planned to be included in both the
at Racal movies but got caught both
times other than this little easter egg
so now the question becomes do I do
carry to the rage for a future episode
of thing
let me know in this poll and whatever
you do decide you're gonna want to make
sure you subscribe to seize these worlds
for new Horrors every week bring the
death battle for notifications use the
link in the description to buy ray cons
and I'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]